as the siren went off like lots of the
Venezuelan women
are crying and you can hear that they're
in distress
and then someone explains me one of the
English guys explains to me that what
the siren is it means that someone's
been killed it means one of the one of
the prisoners it means that something's
gone on internally and that one of the
prisoners is is dead and been killed by
another prisoner and like all the women
that are distressed because maybe it's
their husband or you know their partner
or their brother or their son or
whatever so
I think at first I wasn't sure if I
believed them or not because again it
just sounds like an overwhelming concept
you know that this can can go on in
prison
um but but it does